of fierce females keeping things
crazysexycool at the Teen Choice Awards
Plus Jaden Smith on BFF fever yeah I
just had to tweet I love Justin Bieber
because that's just the fact hey guys
this is the daily Denny you've got to
love that Jaden and Justin bromance
we're on that in just a few but first
you guys season there in that Bruno Mars
video the 20 year old straight burning
up Bruno's new visual for Versace on the
floor and spoiler alert for Versace ends
up on the floor rise India didn't Rob
versace at yesterday's Teen Choice Award
but leave it to her to show up and men's
pajamas and still land on a best-dressed
list that's right he rocked this
sequined and striped two-piece that was
actually modeled by a man at the Ashish
fault runway show Blacky start Yara
Shahidi also opted for comfy chic in
track pants no less she told her she had
a bright orange dress on and decided to
change it up last minute but who
freaking cares because that is how you
glam up a dress down look meanwhile the
ladies of fifth harmony are not messing
around just look at their sophisticated
sexy looks by lavish Alice do not be
fooled y'all
these girls are blossoming into young
women which is why we had to find out
what advice they have for their younger
selves when we caught up with them on
the blue carpet just before the show
advice would you give to your teenage
self love yourself yeah just love
yourself definitely love yourself I'm
making every moment don't try to grow up
too quickly I was gonna have I mean I
have like a teenage sister right now and
she's going through a rough time is like
you know she's all about figure right
now because ups what you see I would
definitely say to be present because I
look back now and I'm like man I just
wanted to be like 21 so bad or 18 and
now that I'm actually 21 I'm like man I
sold I felt like I'm gonna time is not
being kind to me so I would definitely
say be present speaking of presents I've
got one for you
don't forget today is your last chance
to enter for a chance to take home the
official gift bag of the Teen Choice
Award which includes a state of resort
and Costa Rica folks so head over to ET
online.com slash giveaways you must be
18 and over and you have a
till midnight Pacific time to enter so
good luck to you all right from keen
choice to beautycon LA Jaden Smith's hit
the stage at the annual beauty
convention this weekend et's Kevin
Frazier chatted with Jaden exclusively
backstage about his new music and his
pal Justin Bieber who cancelled what was
left of his world tour to focus on
himself yeah I just had to tweet I love
Justin Bieber because that's just in
fact you know I think they is amazing
like honestly like it's like it was a
really cool it's a funny tweet but in
like all honesty like he's really just
like a brother to me will he be okay and
have you checked in with yes yes he will
absolutely be okay and he is okay and
he's totally fine and I love him life is
hard you know we all go through things
it's really difficult for people like
Justin for me for all types of people in
the landline it makes it so much harder
that everybody knows about it then the
actual situation freaks Jaden because
someone who knows that all too well is
Demario Jackson tonight is the premiere
of bachelor in paradise
and is anyone else wondering how much of
what happened between Demario and
Corinne in that pool actually see well
one thing's for sure - mario is ready to
show the tape literally yep that's him
right there with a clear message on his
t-shirt
now Ichi has learned not everything that
went down between Corinne and jamario in
paradise will end up on TV the source
tells us a hook-up won't be shown but
the aftermath will play out with intense
detail will even see Corinne and Demario
hanging out the day after the hookup and
things were quote totally cool between
them definitely yeah you're going to see
plenty of Qurna tomorrow you know
talking with each other
drinking with each other now we had also
heard that Corinne had at least made out
with or spent time with several other
guys in Paradise and I think including
yourself her and jumped on me and I
avoided making out with her and it was
similar to as you've heard from Demario
that she was certainly feeling
aggressive that all I know is a like the
rest of you I will definitely be
watching how that all goes down and then
of course tuning in to Rose's M Rose a
on et's youtube channel tomorrow for the
full wine-soaked recap so be sure to hit
subscribe and head over to ichi
online.com and don't
get to enter for a chance to win that
Teen Choice gift that y'all I'm not
hearing goodbye movies we need you to do
out